hmm
neural real-estate what is that
well
we must begin with when we are born into
the world
during the process of forming inside of
the womb we went from being a simple
couple cell organism to becoming a child
a child with the foundations of all of
the complexity already inside of it
all the organs
off the blood
and everything that began being laid in
the frameworks in architecture
of our central nervous system our brain
is such a critical component to our life
in from the moment that we enter into
the world
every single input every single input
matters
every single input needs to be treated
like it's holy
every single one needs to be treated
like it's divine because that's how we
stay most vigilant and we need to stay
vigilant of what we're taking into our
inputs
and one can go back even further and
think about all of the inputs of their
ancestors and how what that costs to
their neural real-estate to their
essence to their spirit
and then how that affected you and how
that affects you today moment moment
now
as we lay the initial foundations and
architectures of this real estate that
that is so critical especially months
zero to six are so important for all of
the basic needs to be met there needs to
be air there needs to be water there
needs to be food there needs to be love
and compassion there needs to be shelter
there needs to be a basic necessities
met discovery for the child to discover
their purpose and so those any of those
initial foundations are disrupted it
immediately takes effect in the neural
real-estate it immediately causes and
compounds issues down the line we must
recognize this and even further than six
months as well the first year the first
two three years we have to remember how
important those early foundational years
of life are and for the input stream
that goes into the child to be very
vigilant to be very very vigilant all
the basic needs be met so that there's
no issues down the line have it be fun
for the child to discover their purpose
not for them to be boxed into something
that they don't want to do that doesn't
align with their purpose their entire
life
all right well we've laid out all the
way back from ancestors and the central
nervous system developing and these
initial frameworks in the first couple
months and years of developing and then
we we see so much of this process of the
neural networks you lost some ink and
blooming and making more and more
connections gaining a better and better
understanding of the world that the
sentience is in sentience is able to
process the stimuli of its environment
and make decisions and so to do things
like really be vigilant in those first
couple years of what is literally as you
take in the input stream is being formed
up here is so so important that is life
changing
tearing that with you and then of course
getting further into the earlier
childhood and teenager years and then
creeping into the young adult and adult
years look at how much we lack vigilance
with our input stream today we let other
people and organizations control our
input stream rather than us being in
full control of it
that's why even during this show we make
it very clear that come in get what you
need to get inspired to go and create
and go and create we don't want you to
adjust addictively be watching there's
no point go and create with what you're
learning and don't get stuck on the
algorithms and the manipulative
techniques that are being used to
capture people into the internet
technologies that exist today ok that
was a big jump because for a long period
of time in civilizations history there
was no computers and internet technology
and manipulative algorithms that sucked
people's time and attention into the
devices has really only come up in the
last 10 years prior to that though there
were still issues with the way that we
had our neural real-estate be
compromised by people that were self
dealing they had self dealing behaviors
instead of this altruistic inclusive
fitness behaviors and its most visible
because if you go all the way back in
history you can find so many instances
of kin altruistic behavior that was
inclusively fit that I would tell you a
story because it would help your fitness
and it would help mine nowadays and even
before nowadays to the sense even even
pre-industrial revolution even in the
last couple thousands of years there
have been so many people that have been
saying things just so that they can self
deal for themselves and it doesn't
actually help your fitness we have to be
very vigilant of that exact phenomenon
that's occurring be very vigilant who is
self dealing and who is truly selfless
who is self-dealing and who is selfless
because that vigilance with your input
stream can be the difference between you
identifying at a young age that you know
what is bringing you purpose and meaning
and you're not going to get derailed
from that versus someone saying hmm
haven't found that yet we'll let me link
let me hook them in and bring them into
doing things that they may not even find
purpose with doing it makes the
difference with compounding your inputs
into your neuro real estate your spirit
wants to identify and remember that it
came from God that it came from all that
is from creation and then it wants to
identify its purpose and it wants to go
forth and pursue that purpose and if you
at younger ages identify what that is
and focus on that in your input stream
you will compound your level of
connection to your purpose to the
knowledge and information that matters
to you most you do not want a person
that is an adult
even worse a person that is literally
about to die that is saying that they
did not fill their spirit with what was
most important to them throughout their
life that they never truly discovered
what the stimuli were that were most
important to them and this varies for
certain people the inputs into their
real estate are the interactions that
they have with their family and friends
for some people it's building some sort
of a project into the world that updates
the code of civilization that transcends
their own ego it can be any thing but to
be vigilant with the neural real estate
and the input stream from the youngest
ages and how it compounds how it
compounds so that if you learn about the
fields think about it this way
you learn about a field that you're
interested in let's say that that field
is evolution and you learn about
evolution when you're five years old and
seven years old and nine years old
versus if you only learn about evolution
when you're twenty or thirty years old
obviously there's a massive difference
we all by learning language at such
young ages are able to articulate
ourselves this well we also see it super
evidently with people that pick up a
language when they're like five years
old versus when they pick up a language
on there twenty-five years old there is
a massive difference in the level of
competency in the language so the
younger formative years are so important
for the input stream that we take into
this neural real estate and it's so
important to also remember that what
stimuli do you want to take in during
the day
if the stimuli that you take in during
the day are ones that you want to
remember for the rest of your life then
that is fantastic
but if the inputs that were taking in
throughout the day are ones that aren't
that meaningful to us that aren't that
important we only get that day we only
get that day to fill our minds our souls
or spirits with what we want to
experience and if we're having these
oops moments every couple of days or
even worse every day where we're
spending years of our lives not
following our purposes not following
inputting stimuli that we want to retain
gotta remember that when you go to bed
at night the reason why you sleep is so
you can consolidate your memories from
that day with the rest of your life
and so imagine if the inputs of that day
were not profound for you if they
weren't meaningful for you if they
didn't make you feel like you were being
more actualized like if you felt like
you were being manipulated that day if
you felt like the stimuli inputs were
useless that day it's so important to
stay so vigilant that you really only do
things that you find that are most
meaningful more most purposeful for you
and then when you go to bed at night and
the memories consolidate from a very
meaningful and very purposeful day with
the past when you wake up in the morning
you've integrated great memories from
that day with your path with your life
and you go forth into the next day the
Real Estate's so critical I mean we can
we think about reap it repetitive
stimuli repeats stimuli that happened
during the day when we do a same
repetitive task laborious tasks over and
over again we can literally feel
ourselves going on autopilot versus when
we do something that's that's
cognitively challenging plus it is non
repetitive whoa we can literally feel
ourselves hmm okay this is challenging I
haven't done this before maybe I've done
stuff that's similar to it I'm at about
my flow state because it's not too hard
where I'm gonna give up it's not too
easy where I'm gonna say this is too
simple but it's right at that flow State
oh my goodness that is such a delicious
moment of life those moments have so
much much nostalgia saz gorgeous
and if during that day that limited
amount of time is being filled with
stimuli in inputs into this real estate
that is not that fulfilling we have a
massive problem and we need to talk more
with our families our friends co-workers
people online about this amount of
neural real estate that we have and how
we need to be very vigilant with the
input stream that we take in and really
call people call yourself out look in
the mirror and call yourself out for the
decisions that you're making and also
challenge your friends challenge your
families challenge them and ask them
about the inputs that they're taking and
when they're only inputting 1 biased
source of news and they're never
inputting the other by source of news
they have blind spots there's so much
nuance to still take in from taking in
as many of these beautiful world views
as possible and that will help you with
the neuro real-estate that is well
diversified if you have a neural real
estate that is super singular in one
echo chamber that that worldview is
going to be constricted to that one echo
chamber it's like when you have a when
you have them a mouse that's inside of
occasion the cage has absolutely no
nothing in it you can literally see the
neural architecture inside of that Mouse
be not as complex as when the mouse
evolves in a cage that has cool things
for it to do those cool things enable
the mouse to have new stimuli new inputs
that create a more flourishing neural
architecture so remember that when we go
out of this little echo chamber and we
go into new world views we literally lay
down more and better and more
flourishing and more and more the world
view becomes so much more nuanced and
complex and able to hold multivariate
perspectives and multivariate
conversations with people you literally
become
smarter by doing that you gain more
empathy you gain more emotional
intelligence social awareness with
knowing how to probe reality for those
perspectives that give you a stronger
more well-rounded spirit these are such
important things to do and when we
really view this as something that in
its sense it cannot be that you can just
chunk off part of your neuro real-estate
and just say that oh I'm just gonna turn
this off or oh I'm just gonna sell this
to some to someone else in many ways
we at times when we don't if we did
music for a long time and then we
stopped doing music for decades that
though that that in fact it's that neuro
real estate is used for other other
things then it's it's used in two bodies
a very adaptive piece of art and we have
to be super super aware of the way that
they if we're in control of our neuro
real estate or if others are in control
of our neuro real estate and our spirit
if we have any types of fragmentations
with at the beginning when we were
talking about the nourishment that this
spirit needs when it's born into the
world these basic physiological needs
air water food love and compassion
shelter these types of things if those
are missing it makes it easier for the
spirit to be fragmented for then other
manipulative forces to come in and take
advantage of laying their own desires
into the neural real-estate we have to
think about it that way and feel it that
way and remind ourselves why and how am
i connecting to nature how am i
connecting to mother to God to creation
how am i doing that on a daily basis
even through something as simple as
breath am I doing that even through
something as simple as gratitude am I
really doing that am i aligning myself
with my purpose on a moment-to-moment
basis am i is my input stream that I'm
compounding for my future exactly what I
want it to be have your input stream
into your neural real estate into your
spirit be exactly what you want it to be
and do not settle do not settle it needs
to be exactly what you want it to be and
that is so important get to that as fast
as possible to that possibility as fast
as possible and be in full control of
what is laid into your essence laid into
your spirit and to this beautiful neural
infrastructure that lies within us
all right everyone thank you for tuning
into this stream of consciousness on
neural real estate appreciate it get
talking to more of your friends families
co-workers people online about this
subject get talking question your own
input stream question their input
streams get talking about this more and
build the future build the future I love
you very much thank you for tuning in
and let me know your thoughts and
comments below on these streams of
consciousness would love to hear from
you subscribe if you haven't
follow across the other channels if you
haven't need to keep sharing content
like this keep it going
I love you very much talk to you soon
peace